für auswärtige Angelegenheiten das schon
heute aber auch in der Zukunft eine ganz
ganz große Rolle spielen wird für die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes wir
wissen dass wir hoch attraktiv sind dass
viele mal Urlaub machen wollen in
Deutschland das ganz viele auch das
Bedürfnis haben hier zu studieren zu
arbeiten die Zukunft für sich selber zu
gewinnen und für uns geht es ja auch
darum wir wissen dass wir unsere Zukunft
die Leistungsfähigkeit unserer
Volkswirtschaft die Leistungsfähigkeit
auch unser sozialen Sicherungssysteme
nur gewährleisten können wenn wir über
genügend Fachkräfte verfügen aus der
Europäischen Union ist das nicht so
schwierig denn da gibt es Freizügigkeit
im Hinblick auf die übrigen Welt ist das
eine größere Herausforderung und das
muss ja alles geordnet nach Regeln vor
sich gehen es darf da nichts schief
gehen wenn das passiert und darum ist es
wichtig dass wir eine
hochleistungsfähige Behörde haben die
Entscheidung des Auswärtigen Amtes hier
eine Behörde in Brandenburg hier zu
etablieren ist wichtig sie ist
zukunftsweisen sie ist die Grundlage
dafür dass wir das schaffen auch
übrigens im Zusammenhang mit all den
notwendigen digitalisierungsprozessen
und da geht es ja nicht nur darum heute
vorhandene Verfahren die auf dem Papier
da sind irgendwie zu digitalisieren
sondern wir müssen in der
Digitalisierung auch unglaubliche
Effizienz Gewinne möglich machen damit
die Arbeit einfacher wird und sich auf
das Wesentliche konzentrieren kann
grundlage dafür sind natürlich auch ganz
viele tolle Frauen und Männer die hier
arbeiten die hier an diesem Standort oft
auch wohnen und die hier etwas aufbauen
das für die Zukunft Deutschlands wichtig
ist und darüber freue ich mich und ich
bin sehr dankbar dafür dass das der Fall
ist für mich war das und auch für die
Außenministerin ein ganz erfreulicher
Besuch und wir glauben darauf können wir
aufbauen für eine der ganz großen
Herausforderungen Aufgaben
der die sich unserem Land stellen
eine weitere Bemerkung würde ich gerne
noch machen
ich habe Boris Pistorius gebeten
Bundesminister der Verteidigung zu
werden er ist nicht nur ein Freund und
ein guter Politiker sondern auch jemand
der über sehr sehr viele Erfahrungen in
der Sicherheitspolitik verfügt der sehr
offen und eng auch in seiner bisherigen
Funktion mit der Bundeswehr
zusammengearbeitet hat und der auch die
Kraft und Ruhe besitzt die man für eine
so große Aufgabe angesichts der jetzigen
Zeitenwende braucht ich bin überzeugt
dass das jemand ist der mit der Truppe
kann und den die Soldaten und Soldaten
sehr mögen werden und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass er ja gesagt hat und wir
freuen uns auf die gute Zusammenarbeit
mit dem Minister aus Pistorius ich will
nicht versorgen mich auch noch mal bei
der Bundesministerin der Verteidigung zu
bedanken für Ihre Arbeit die sie
geleistet hat und noch mal klar sagen
großer Respekt für die Entscheidung die
sie gestern getroffen hat schönen Dank
Holz in Brandenburg an der Havel beim
Bundesamt für auswertete Angelegenheiten
Gerd es heißt ja immer die Personalie
sei intern schon länger bekannt dass
Frau Lambrecht aufhören will wieso hat
man da versäumt sage ich mal gleich
Nägel mit Köpfen zu machen und
vielleicht gestern zumindest schon einen
Nachfolger zu haben es hieß immer so ein
bisschen drum herum geredet ich habe
einen klar vor Augen man weiß aber nicht
ist es der jetzt gewesen der klar vor
Augen hatte oder ist er doch vielleicht
noch einer abgesprungen also war das
nicht in letzter Minute noch mit sehr
heißer Nadel im Hintergrund gestrickt
wie ist da ihre Einschätzung
nun das war es das hatte Boris Pistorius
ja auch bestätigt dass er gestern erst
angerufen worden ist seit Freitagabend
spätestens wusste der Kanzler das Frau
Lambrecht jetzt aufhören will in der
völlig falschen Woche übrigens und in
der Tat verdichten sich die Hinweise
darauf dass man schon nach dem Silvester
Video offensichtlich mit ihrem Gespräch
war und dass sich diese Trennung
abgezeichnet hat wo es Pistole es hat ja
gesagt er ist gestern angerufen worden
er ist tatsächlich nur zweite Wahl das
soll nicht den Mann schmälern sondern
zeigen in welcher Schwierigkeit der
Bundeskanzler gesteckt hat nachdem seine
drei außen und sicherheitspolitischen
Experten die wir ja gestern diskutiert
haben offensichtlich alle drei abgewinkt
haben und man ist schon verwundert wie
der Kanzler sich hat überraschen lassen
können von dieser Personalie und
wirklich auch jetzt diese
Pressekonferenz das sind nur
Kleinigkeiten aber auch das ist
verunglückt natürlich hätte man in
Hannover warten müssen bis der
Bundeskanzler zu der Personalie Stellung
genommen hat der Bundeskanzler war jetzt
20 Minuten zu spät aber es ist eben so
der Kanzler ist die Nummer eins und das
muss Boris pistorisch in seiner Leute
noch lernen man hätte in Hannover diese
Pressekonferenz einfach ein wenig später
abhalten müssen aber das sind
Kleinigkeiten dieser Rücktritt und der
Neuanfang jetzt auch drei Tage später
als unbedingt nötig denn jetzt die
letzten zwei Tage ist Frau Lambrecht
nicht mehr sozusagen im Ministerium es
ist nicht verweist de facto ist sie dann
noch bis zur Überreichung der
Entlassungsurkunde die Ministerin aber
das sind alles unglückliche
Voraussetzungen das ist von vorne bis
hinten schief gegangen ab Donnerstag
muss der Neustart gelingen
gehört gilt als Hardliner haben wir eben
beschrieben er gilt als Mann mit klarer
Kante im konservativen Kreis der SPD
vorortet das heißt doch für mich
zwischen den Zeilen gelesen er wird
erstens sehr schnell bestellen Stichwort
Munition für die Bundeswehr und er wird
auch eine sehr offensive Linie fahren
was die Waffenlieferungen in Richtung
Ukraine angeht also vielleicht doch
Leopard 2 in die Ukraine
ich glaube er wird am Freitag in
Ramstein noch nicht über die
Möglichkeiten und die Autorität verfügen
das einfach so zu bestimmen das muss er
abstimmen mit Wolfgang Schmidt im
Kanzleramtsminister und mit dem
Bundeskanzler wie in Zukunft auch aber
er führt dann das Resort und in der Tat
wird er anders als Frau Lambrecht
agieren er wird zuhören am Anfang und
wird dann tatsächlich schneller
bestellen er hat ja einen kleinen
Vorteil bei allen schwierigen Aufgaben
die auf ihn warten die Bundeswehr ist
relativ gut jetzt mit Geld ausgestattet
20 Milliarden haben wir gehört bräuchte
ist alleine für neue Munition und die
braucht es offensichtlich also muss er
dort schnell aktiv werden und das wird
er sicherlich tun er hat ja gesagt ab
Donnerstag wird der zuhören er wird
versuchen das Ministerium kennenzulernen
er wird sich den verteidigungspolitikern
im Bundestag stellen und da kommt viel
auf ihn zu also den Urlaub für dieses
Jahr den kann er mal getrost streichen
danke
ja wir schauen was Lars klingt weil zu
sagen hat der SPD-Chef und anschließend
sprechen wir weiter mit den Kollegen
zur Frage der Parität will ich das sehr
deutlich und klar beantworten die ist
dem Bundeskanzler wichtig die ist uns
als Parteiführung wichtig die bleibt
auch wichtig aber wir hatten jetzt in
den vergangenen Tagen in einer konkreten
Personalfrage zu entscheiden